if he lacks any form of basic gentleman
skills and with gentleman skills come on
I think this is very Universal we don't
even really have to pay attention to
cultures I think that holding up the
door for a woman rather than throwing it
in her face is basic manners all men
kind of know about right or let's say as
an example you're walking next to the
man and it's a little bit chilly you're
wearing a short sleeve top or something
like that and it's a little bit cold and
he doesn't offer to give give his jacket
to you or one of the things that I see a
lot and this I think you also know is
when the man is so nonchalant doesn't
really care about his woman he walks in
front of her he doesn't even wait for
her doesn't even look back to see if
she's still behind him you know so rude
and not gentleman whatsoever you know
small things like that that really shows
if a if a man is a gentleman I think
that women should open doors for
men W absolutely